okay Maxim ready we're two minutes late
okay guys
welcome back to the afternoon where
you're all coffeed up
um
uh our first speaker is Victoria
Castillo from Caltech and take it
thanks Lalita
I am very excited to highlight this
joint work with Chang William who was a
student at Caltech and who is now at
Kronos research in Taiwan and Baba
kasibi who is a professor at Caltech
training of a large-scale machine
learning models involves performing
gradient descent or related iterative
algorithms to minimize an objective
function f
gradient descent moves the internet
um the model parameter X
in the direction of
steepest Descent of function f and here
ETA is a constant step size that is
chosen beforehand and it's important for
optimal conversions to choose this step
size
judiciously because if ETA is too large
they either bounce around too much if
it's too small then too many steps are
required for convergence in distributed
training the worker
computes the gradients and the server
successively refines the model parameter
the undecides when to stop the
distributed optimization based on the
target accuracy or delay constraints
exchanging High dimensional gradients
presents a real bottleneck in
distributed optimization
this communication delay significantly
slows down the overall training process
and for this reason in recent years
there's been an explosion of interest in
methods designed to alleviate this
communication burden in exchanging this
High dimensional gradients
a large body of this work focuses on
designing quantizers
for stochastic ingredients descent
another line of this work focuses on
gradient specification where
several significant components of each
High dimensional gradient
are preserved and the rest are discarded
and the components that are preserved
are communicated with infinite precision
and the
proxy for rate in this line of work is
the number of components that are
preserved
I
I would like to highlight only very few
Works in this very large body of work
the work that really started it all was
this 2014 paper
which made a striking observation that
quantizing the ingredients down to one
bit per Dimension that is sending just
the sign of the gradient
I'm completely discarding its magnitude
results in almost no
loss in empirical convergence
so this is a very important inset
because what it
told people is that there is a massive
space for improvement in terms of
communication that is required in
distributed optimization so we do not
need to send those entire High
dimensional gradients there is a lot we
can do by with compression
so so this uh this led to all this other
works that uh later uh studied
analytical
convergence guarantees for for these
kinds of arguments or these kinds of uh
problems and I propose different uh
variants for uh for the for this
algorithm
another important idea and prior work
that I would like to highlight is what
they call Air compensation or error
feedback and what it is it's simply the
idea that
you shouldn't quantize the agreement
directly instead you should add back
previous quantization errors you should
compensate previous quantization errors
before
quantizing the the ingredients
and uh and actually it was the same
paper so the same paper that that
started that noticed that one bit
quantization uh doesn't uh result in in
a performance loss that uh also noticed
that we should um we should compensate
uh past quantization errors
and I should also notice uh I should
also note in in um
that a lot of Prior work uh
is in indeed focuses on
characterizing uh the convergence of
naive what we call it in in our paper
naive consideration so naive
quantization would just
directly quantize the the gradient
without doing any error compensation
and then of course follow-up Works uh
extended
further uh
deepened this idea of error compensation
but what I would like to note here is
that
the idea of air compensation actually in
in information Theory literature dates
but is a classical idea uh known under
as the name Sigma Delta modulation
uh okay another point I would like to
make about the prior work is that
uh some uh some some of his prior Works
they provide an algorithm and they
provide analytical performance
guarantees for that argument for that
algorithm but convergence lower bounds
what we call um Converses are very
scarce
and uh that's why I thought it would be
appropriate to mention these two papers
that um
that stand out in in that sense because
they do provide a Converse however the
converse is limited in the sense that
they restrict their a class of
algorithms they focus on too much they
actually only focus on naive
quantization so they fix the input to
the quantizer to be the gradient of the
currency threat
nevertheless they do look at lower
bounds and so I thought it would be this
works will be worth mentioning
okay so what we do we
uh take an information theoretic
approach to the problem and we provide
the necessary and sufficient bit rate
necessary to achieve a Target conversion
speed so we provide both the converse
result which says that you cannot do uh
better than a certain performance within
some class of algorithms and we also
provide a a scheme an actual ability
result which
attains this bond with equality
I would like to set up the problem
formally and um
we
have we we fix the class of functions to
be the following so I denoted by F sub n
and this this standard assumptions and
a lot of optimization literature so we
assume that f is L smooth
which which is the definition is here
and we assume that it's new strongly
convex alternative way of thinking about
this is that simply that F can be
sandwiched between those two quadratic
functions mu uh the quadratic function
is coefficient mu from below and one is
coefficient L from above
so in certain sense it performs like a
quadratic function
and we also make the standard assumption
that the minimizer lives in a bounded
set
okay so this is important because uh
because obviously once we we cannot in
practice we cannot guarantee that our
functions are nice like this and so it's
a very interesting uh direction for
future work to try to drop some of its
assumptions and in fact that's a lot of
a lot of present work is doing is
focused on in in these directions
was that demonstrated on non-convex uh
um
I don't believe it was non-conomics it
was mostly experimental they didn't
provide the they didn't provide the
analytical performance currencies what
was it done on like neural networks
I think so yes yes
okay so uh
before before speaking about what what
is the fundamental limits achievable
with quantized gradient descent let's
recall some classical results about the
vanilla gradient descent
the following results due to poorly
access that for any else smooth and new
strongly convex function f
are unquantized gradient descent uh
satisfies the following conversions
guarantee
so the iterate at step C minus the true
meaning true minimizer taking the norm
of that is upper bounded by Sigma raised
to poverty
um times the norm of the of the initial
uh the starting point minus the optimize
minus the optimizer
so here's Sigma we refer to Sigma as the
contraction factor of gradient descent
right so what what the result says is
that gradient distance converges
exponentially fast with this factor and
this factor is between zero and one
and it depends on the condition number
of f
um
so the the larger the conditional number
the worse the contraction factor is like
worse means larger okay
and uh what's interesting is that this
bound is actually tight in the sense
that there exists uh worst case problem
instance F such that such that we can
attain equality in this uh in in this
result
so okay the question we ask is that what
is the smallest
the best contraction Factor achievable
uh with our bits per iteration
and when we say our bits we need to
formally introduce the problem what do
we mean by by arbits what is the class
and what sense do we mean this and we
chose to to consider the simplest
possible quantizers
um and
one important thing about this work is
that there is no Randomness on it
actually there is Randomness in one
result I'm gonna point out how it comes
in but there is no Randomness everything
is worst case so it's very simple in a
sense really mentoring
without without probability uh what is
what is the quantize the quantities of
Dimension n and rate R is simply a
function from from some domain D to to
uh RN where
um such that the image of Q satisfies uh
satisfies this condition so there are
two to the NR points that this function
Q Maps uh our domain to
and this is uh in high dimension and low
dimension
uniform scalar quantizer for example
of this
so quantization rate for us it's simply
the log of this number of the
cardinality of the image of Q divided by
by n
um and we can also talk about uh
relevant quantities that measure the
performance of such quantizers
dynamic range of a quantizer q is is the
radius of a ball right so here this blue
region is our domain and then the radius
of the largest ball that can be
inscribed inside of this domain is what
we call dynamic range this is just done
to generalize we know the original
notion we're used to uh for scale
quantizers
um the usual notion of
dynamic range to to multiple Dimensions
covering radius of
quantizer Q is simply the uh the radius
of the of the smallest
Distortion ball with which that set of
quantization points covers the entire
space
so the covering radius uh the
requirementizer queue is covering radius
D is guaranteed to cover our domain up
to Distortion d
okay so everything is worst case there's
no no probability here and then covering
it and so how do we compare it to
different quantizers
again here we simply extend this
classical notion of covering efficiency
which is uh which has been developed in
the context of hilarious quantizers to
to this quantizers this bounded domain
so covering efficiency uh is is this
quantity and it's a quantity that's
between one and
um so it's greater than or equal to one
and one corresponds to a perfect
covering with Distortion D balls what
they mean by perfect covering if I could
um if I could if I could cover a set
perfectly with this this and dimensional
balls without any overlap between them
this is what I would get I would get
covering efficiency of one
but in
uh in a practically implementable
quantizers this would be a quantity that
is greater than one and for example
Universal killer quantizer would achieve
a covering efficiency of square return
nice also it's not the best quantizer
right you can in high dimension you can
you can you can find better better
coverings and a classical result of
Rogers says that um
Infinity
the covering efficiency of
arbitrarily close to one is is
achievable okay and this is the only
result that uses Randomness in the stock
because because in to show this he uses
around the blackest Construction
foreign
so this is a class of algorithms that
has been extensively studied and what
what it does it simply quantizes the the
gradient directly so it doesn't do
anything else it just quantizes
um the gradient sends it back and then
the parameter server operates in exactly
the same manner as it would have
operated without the quantization
and so what we can do we can analyze the
performance of this algorithm and we can
show that the achievable uh contraction
factor is bounded by uh by this quantity
Where Sigma is the achievable
contraction factor of unquantized
gradient descent and then you have this
um communication cost which is a
function of covering efficiency rate and
also a function of condition number
of the function f
so one thing to notice about this is
Argos in GC then we can recover the
contraction factor of unquantized
gradient descent
another thing to be aware of is that
this is not the best scheme because what
happens is that in the analysis is that
this quantization errors they accumulate
iteration to iteration and this results
in this additive penalty term
so we can actually do do better than
this significantly better than this
and how do we do better well we we do
better by relaxing this uh naive
assumption that the quantize that the
quantizer should directly quantize the
gradient and instead we we say okay the
class of algorithms we're going to focus
on is gonna ask the worker to construct
uh
z i the gradient access point and
construct UI the quantizer input based
on the current iterate and the past
quantization errors
okay so we give this additional freedom
to the uh to the worker uh to to decide
what it is that it should send to the
parameter server so as to uh to maximize
the conversion speed uh in this context
okay so in a sense it's context aware
communication so we want to really
design our
quantize their input too much this
particular uh
quite a particular action that's
happening at the parameter server okay
this is the another constraint that we
have here is that the parameter server
simply performs this uh this
update
maybe it I know there's more good in the
sense this question but stochastic we
understand will create a noise and if
this threshold is smaller I don't have
to worry about this I could get this my
quantization is fine I suppose I could
get away with it
I'm not sure I understand the question
we do not look at uh we look at the
vanilla gradient this one but there's
been a lot of work actually the most
work in this uh in this domain concerns
uh concerns quantizing stochastic
some
okay but I can see here as you say if I
keep quantizing the variance I'm
creating this error in the updates so
yeah so my point is going to be that yes
yeah I'm creating it exactly so I'm you
can think of this uh that could be
viewed as a stochastic even yeah yeah
actually that's what's the angle that
that a lot of previous analysis take
they they look at this added
quantization errors as a noise like so
so it pulls into this larger framework
of a noisy stochastic ingredients you
snap and then they assume they make some
some further assumptions about the
quantization error for example
um they they make assumptions that the
quantizer is unbiased and then they can
they can show some some performance guys
yes yes yes
nothing sarcastic is here
other questions
okay oh right so we widen we we widen
the optimization Space by giving more
freedom to the worker and so we what I'm
gonna claim next is that you can do much
better than what naive quantization does
okay so this is this is just a formal
definition for the uh worst case
contraction Factor achievable uh with
within uh bye-bye uh quantized algorithm
a so informally maybe just look here so
informally what this means is that
um yeah the the internets behave like
this so you have exponentially fast
convergence um and we ignore the sub
exponential factors and we're going to
characterize this point
and this is the main well the converse
to the menu is out which says that the
contraction factor of any contrast the
ideas and algorithm operating at our
bits or problem Dimension satisfies the
following in the chords
and uh so so you can see on the right
hand side here it's a maximum of the two
coincidence the sigma which is the
contraction
factor of unquantized gradient distance
and 2 to the minus r uh which is the
cost due to due to quantization
uh and the proof of this combines two
Converses that's by reduction to one
quantized gauge is descent we can claim
that we cannot do anything better than
what what we can do with our full
information and the second amount is
simply the volume division argument so
it's the same argument that's used to
show that for covering efficiency of any
quantizers is lower bounded by one okay
so it simply gives you 2 to the minus r
here so it's ridiculously simple what's
amazing about this is that we can
actually achieve this
okay and how do we achieve this
uh we achieved this is the idea we call
differential quantization
and what it does the the main idea
behind this is that we we should
compensate that so we should we should
compensate the past quantization errors
and how should we compensate them we
should compensate them by directing
sociality so so in this picture X naught
X1 X2 this this is the uncle the the
trajectory of the unquantized algorithm
this is the trajectory of the quantized
algorithm so so what I do I uh every
time I I wanted at every time instance I
want to direct my my trajectory back to
the unquantized to the unquantized
trajectory and I form on my if I form my
quantizer inputs in that way
um then
um then I would be able to attain that
Converse result that I showed uh one
curious observation here is that it's
the the same state step size uh is
optimal as the uncontest Gated descent
so originally we thought okay maybe a
different step size would would be
better for a quantized algorithm but in
fact it's exact same uh step size that
attains the optimal contraction factor
for Creative descent
has the same steps as to
because it depends on what kind of a
trip can lose is it looking at it I
forget
um
okay so yeah but what's important to
note about this yourself
yes so uh is this is it true that in
depending on the rage you will be either
dominated by directing or just
basically that monetization is going to
be negligible versus so you always do
the same thing you always do this like
that's a cell game like that's the
algorithm it doesn't depend on the rate
you're always you always do this
depending on your rates depending on
your rate you attain one of one of the
two uh contraction factors you attend
either two to the minus r if your rate
is too low or you obtain Sigma if your
rate is high enough right so I
understand but what I was trying to ask
is that
so if the rate is is too low then it
just maybe it doesn't just look like as
if you're just directing towards the the
trajectory all the time and then if the
trace is too high you're doing basically
it's as if you just don't care like one
thousand one position or not that much
yeah so if my rate is high enough or
what the result says without an analysis
of this automation says that effectively
I don't lose anything and so that's what
I was going to say next there is a
threshold like the amazing thing about
this is a threshold which is finite
isolate Uranus is greater than this
finite threshold then then we don't lose
anything with this quantization as
you're saying we are always actually
able to direct our projectile back to
the uncontized one and admire it is less
than again the spine coincidence
um then I I pay pen also
foreign
and we attain the converse exactly
um okay proof's case uh proof is also
pretty simple so we perform some
induction so they are quantized and
uncontest trajectory related by by this
equality and then we have two terms the
first term is Convergence of gradient
descent and the second term uh we choose
the dynamic range of the quantizer
carefully so that we can guarantee that
we are always quantizing the
um the the quantization error
up to up to Distortion d
so basically what we want to we want to
guarantee that the the dynamic range
that we chose is enough to cover the
uncertainty about the the cut to cover
the influences about the quantization
error
and uh this is some numerical results so
here uh we we show okay conversion
Street this should be
a contraction Factor okay so low is good
high is bad and this is our data rate
per Dimension the uncontest gradient
descent achieves the slide
and the naive quantization achieves this
green curve and differential
quantization achieves this this red
curve
and from the previous slide so you're
saying the dynamic range has to change
per iteration yes we we have to adjust
so there's a formula with
there's a recurrence
occurrence which
which probably should adjust the dynamic
range and but that's known ahead of time
where you have to do that on the Fly
that you can compute ahead of time so
yeah yeah based on the class of
functions that that you have
yes
is it your results seems to say the dqs
dqgd would have dissent even at
like very low rates
right but it seems to have those
convergence thing because this is that
are the red lines at one some kind of
artifact of plotting oh this one yeah we
we clicked the conversion site at one if
it's uh if it's like greater than one
then you cannot attend linear
convergence rate
if I'm using two bits per dimension
[Music]
oh what's your is it because of the row
like why in your if you go back to your
previous I thought I thought there was
always for any R greater than zero it
would
um
uh let me see what this
didn't understand what the oh okay
because that's the formula so here okay
so this is uh I think what yeah
we're uploading it for for uniform
skeletons so there's a penalty for being
practical rightful so we are not
actually approaching uh it was optimal
uh raw juice one thousand it was the
beginning
and yes and you can do better than this
by applying uh applying back to
quantization new connection with this
curves this one suggests for scale
advantages uh so what you can see is
that there's differential quantization
actually the difference is massive right
compared to life fertilization you gain
like what two two bits per Dimension
easily and that's problem Dimension and
dimensions is large
okay so I think I should come through
right now
[Music]
so yeah we tried this with other um uh
real world so so this was a gaussian
Ensemble and then we also uh decided
with a real world Matrix and observed
the same thing
and um
um
yeah so that's the main result and I
just want to briefly mention the couple
of extensions I wanted to mention that
we can also extend the same idea to
gradient methods with momentum so
gradient methods with momentum they
leverage the memory of the past to
further accelerate convergence so we can
apply the same idea uh the idea is to
direct the the quantized trajectory
towards the unquantized one to also show
similar results for this class of
algorithms and we we look at two
accelerated algorithms The Accelerated
gradient descent and heavy Ball Method
and for both of those methods we can we
can show that similar conclusions
hold
um and so the conclusion is
uh in all three cases uh if there is a
finite threshold if rate is greater than
this finite threshold then
differentially quantized algorithm
attains the contraction factor of the
case by an uncontested
takeaways so the optimal um so we looked
at the optimal trade-off between
conversion speed and bit rate we
formulated the problem and as a worst
case problem
and what we observed is that it creates
the leveraged memory like so
differential critization is much better
than naive quantization which discards
the memory about past quantization
errors and there is a lot of future
directions where one can take this for
example a very intriguing one a very
natural one is how do we do gradient
descent over noisy channels perhaps
there is a formulation where you have
a bounded noise and we can ask what is
the amount of noise that you can
tolerate and what is the trade-off
between conversion speed and the noise
in this channel also very interesting to
relax the conditions on F and to extend
this to multi-worker
um uh gradient descent where uh where
the the challenge is to figure out how
each of the workers should compensate
their own
uh communication errors because in
multi-worker you cannot really compute
the uncontact each worker cannot compute
the unquantized um trajectory so so this
is a
Converse still applies to this case we
don't know there is a gap between
natural built-in colors so if anyone is
interested let's talk about this
yes so I was wondering if you just out
of curiosity have you tested the
differential quantization method in a
longer
I know you can
but just yes
problems yes so no not yet but yeah
analytical is alcohol sorry
the young Brothers
any other questions
just like